اعاده شارع الاستقلال وسط اسطنبول الى
سابق عهده قبل انفجار يوم الاحد الماضي
لكن احوال الحادث ما زالت عالقه في اذهان
واجساد الكثيرين احمد مترجم في مركز
التجميل اصيب في يده وقدمه بعده شظايا
نتيجه التفجير كان على بعد امتار قليله
فقط من القنبله
حسيت انه يعني اول انفجار
لما طلعت بدي سياره
اخرى في السياسه التركيه لن تم حاب بسهوله
والروايه التي قدمتها السلطات عن الحادث
ستحدد لمن سينحاز الناخب في الانتخابات
القادمه ووافقه محللين اذا ظهرت ان هناك
ضلوع لتنظيم الارهابي في هذه العمليه ترد
عليه الحكومه بقوه في هذا سيصب في صالح
الحكومه ولكن اذا اتضح ان هناك التضارب في
المعلومات
عاده الاضواء مجددا نحو حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي الموا الاكراد والذي طالب
لائتلاف الحاكم باغلاقه وحظر قياداته
واعضائه من العمل السياسي على الجهه
المقابله تبدو طريقه تنفيذ الهجوم فرصه
للمعارضه فزعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري كمال
كلشدار اوغلو شن هجوما على اردوغان وحكوته
منتقدا القصور الامني الذي اداه الى وقوع
ضحايا
تحت شعار مكافحه الارهاب تضغط على الحريات
والحقوق الديمقراطيه بينما على الطرف
الاخر عند المعارضه مختلف انهم يضغطون
الوصول اليه
لكنهم لا يلقون اجابه لا تبدو الانتخابات
القادمه كغيرها من الانتخابات التي شهدتها
البلاد في اخر عقدين انتخابات في مقدماتها
ومؤشراتها الاوليه تستحضر كل الملفات الى
طاوله الصراع بين الائتلاف الحاكم
والمعارضه ولا شك ان تفجير لن يكون خارج
هذه المعادله زيدان زينجو العربيه اسطنبول